[Musique]
retraités alexandre au pc course et pour
ce qui est des prix rien n'est plus
comme avant
ce qui m'a étonné c'est le prix de ces
poivrons
277 euros le kilo sauf sûrement pour des
légumes c'est un prix fou
depuis l'invasion de l'ukraine et la
dégringolade du rouble l'inflation est
galopante
alors comme tout les russes alexandre
doit s'adapter
le jus de fruits par exemple je ne peux
pas prendre celui que j'ai envie je dois
chercher des articles en réduction
pour l'aider à relativiser alexandre
peut compter sur les chaînes de la
télévision russe
vous voyez le monde entier est en
déficit il n'y a pas que chez nous que
les prix augmentent
parfois alexandre sans qu'on ne lui dit
pas tout
je me dis que probablement c'est vrai
parce qu'on dirait que c'est vrai
vraiment on dirait mais en même temps on
ne dirait pas du tout mais alors pas du
tout mais on ne peut pas l'exclure non
plus que même si on ne dirait peut-être
pas il est possible que ce soit vrai
mais lorsqu'il entend certains messages
de propagande alexandre doute vraiment
une attaque de l'ukraine contre la
crimée sans doute ils savent que ça
aurait été une guerre ouverte avec la
russie pourtant alexandre soutient son
pays et son président voit les sommes
accusés poutine de tous les maux c'est
comme accuser ce talent il semble que de
se passer le cours politique et
historique qui les a forcé à prendre de
telles décisions il n'avait pas le choix
comprenez moi bien je suis russe et je
vois mal comment je pourrais ne pas
soutenir mon pays je peux être critique
ou ne pas l'aimer mais dans une telle
situation je dois le soutenir c'est
comme une épouse une bonne épouse peut
penser que son mari a raison ou non mais
dans tous les cas elle doit se tenir à
ses côtés pour recharger ses munitions
alexandre porte ce trait de caractère
plus que jamais vitale pour les russes
la résignation